okay yeah hello and welcome to the video
playing f MZ ah Mahmood okay so what do
we get maybe you can also transpose to a
king's indian still no he plays the
slide know immediately is correct and
then whole line is borderline incorrect
for black would see your fans I managed
to punish this and it's been a while
since I looked looked it up why it is so
bad so that's often addition you look at
you look up line and see okay this is
complete rubbish and then you forget
about it so should be three I guess so
let's win material okay 27 you can play
on it didn't win material I could have
played nine ft 4 and he resigned pudding
freaky but ok but he decided to blunder
stuff instead that's also good what kind
of name is that hey oh my god yeah now
this is again okay this line is is
pretty awful for black I'm not quite
sure what the best continuation is you
can switch this on can switch this view
on I'm not sure what likes relatively
best continuation is this all as a very
shady reputation you see with the the
comp I'm already but I think this is not
working at all like this
586 Bishop en queens is six I think I
also could have done this right okay
Queenie seven is just about holding okay
looks pretty awful but maybe it does
hold so 9 a-7 actually what's correct
what okay you can still do this this
position is certainly good for white but
it doesn't feel completely completely
terrible how much if he gave this and
then gave away this what was that you
can still take here and play it's why
does an exchange up like this this but
black has gotten the center porn at
least for it so it is somewhat playable
at least as you see the engine is just
on a class one score so you can
definitely and try to find ok guys
thanks for watching
[Music]